so the new york times saying i mean the
headline is pretty crazy right
it says off-world vehicles not made on
this earth
that's what they're saying the pentagon
is saying right
so i looked it up and apparently the
pentagon
hired a subcontractor consultant
who's an astrophysicist and he's the one
that said that some of the materials
that the pentagon
apparently has in their possession he
himself doesn't believe they're from
this
earth so it could be from something else
they're saying uh russians rogan had a
guy in a show
you know who's balls deep in this and
russians got really
back in the day got really into it and
had when they would see one of these
ufos
they would send their fighter pilots out
but they couldn't keep up
yeah all they want is the technology
they want the technology to [ __ ] with
everybody
so russian so the question is is if
other countries
have advanced their technology so far
ahead of us that we can't tell
other worlds it could be other worlds
yeah they're also they're kind of like
chinese or russian
yeah yeah so sure they don't know it's
just that of chinese yeah
who knows who knows yeah and did you did
you have you heard that expert on rogan
talking about by the
ufo expert and he was saying they you
know won the they would go around where
we'd have you know nuclear bombs and
stuff they'd go around russia with
nuclear bombs
and they you know they they felt like
they were going there to see what we had
and then they'd take off have you guys
ever seen anything crazy like that
never never a ufo yeah like what you
thought was a ufo i wouldn't shut up
about it
no i'd be a [ __ ] blabber mouth oh
we'd both you did the i'd be like
i saw you kill us i mean yeah i'd be
telling you have i ever not talked about
everything that happens with me
my lids my testosterone a ufo i try to
be
you know if brian's like you know what i
think now is the time my friends know
everything about me
i'm not good at everyone knows
everything about you yeah i don't think
why keep secrets
why i just would rather live a life
where people know
everything about me i definitely believe
there's something going on you know so i
was driving back from
arizona from lake havasu to california
how long ago
this is i don't know
take a look 10 years ago so me and my
friend brian were driving by and we're
we're on the 40 i think it was uh and
then we saw we pulled over because we
saw lights
and apparently there's supposed to be a
military base somewhere around there we
saw
three lights go up and then move
like like this and then and then take
off yeah
it was just like either technology that
we just couldn't understand or who knows
we both saw it together drones moved
like that but it was so far and so
like bright and it was moving so fast
and it's stopping usually i don't have
those lights like that
there's a homeless guy outside of my
thing and he goes oh no
and he had a he goes this is my alien i
go what he got a squash
and he cut out eyes oh senator rubio
senator rubio
i would say that frankly this is some
from outside this planet that might
actually be better than the fact that
we've seen some technology leap on
behalf of the chinese or russians
he's hoping it would he would rather
have it be from another planet than
chinese or russians and
russia the chinese i don't think it is
though if you gave north korea this
technology we're [ __ ] yeah i don't
think the chinese and the russians are
that you don't think chinese are pretty
advanced yeah
but the americans are pretty advanced
too and all the countries are very
secretive about what they have
you know so for sure we'll see we don't
hear anything out of russia
they just [ __ ] with all our stuff yeah
russia doesn't have a lot of innovation
technology well in space not really
their military is really not [ __ ] either
comparison if you hear like actual
muslims don't have the infrastructure
well if when we eventually do which i
think we will go to war with china
i do think we're gonna they're a problem
right now they don't have they're not in
our
they don't have our technology but china
china
not military-wise they'll have the same
technology as us they never really
needed it they haven't
until very recently they didn't put a
lot of resources into their military
because it was all about economics you
know for them um
they never never really that word wars
would be so different now too
right like it's not like you know nobody
wants to go to war because there's no
profit in it but people go to war
because there's a profit but to go into
war
but now now it seems we should take
business
that doesn't really how the economy
works anymore it's such a global
marketplace
with the trade market in china yeah make
a lot of money in that bubble i know but
what i'm saying is that you don't need
to go into another country to take it
over
you can own africa without using weapons
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[ __ ] disrespect